海南的美食街我们来了，
这么大啊，
全住满了这儿，
那出差标准这么高了吗？
多少钱？
这房子一拆，
这就得1000多块钱嘛，
那其实它只是一个这么大，
木有这个吧，
妈耶，
你给我整个海景房就行，
来海南选择就咱解出群必须得这标准，
就我在海南生活过差不多一年，
就是海南人醋啊，
他不怎么用那个醋，
他就用那个小的柠檬直接挤上去当醋，
很好吃，
很清香哇，
我口水才流出来了香味，
当时猪肚鸡还有糟粕醋，
哎呀。
我也流口水，
椰子要去吃一下子咯，
你捞不凉要去吃，
在飞机上拍了一个你很丑很丑的照片啊200我就删了小龙虾吃不吃老板哎，
你们要什么？
这个多少钱？
30块钱一份一杯一斤便一斤，
很有食欲圆大这也是有个拿吧好吗？
满满的汤汁愿这个我们待会回家拿吧，
拿以给你钱付了你怎么知道的，
但这边不能我下来了，
好吃的呀，
我吃过呀好，
那你买了你吃不是呃，
一份打包带走吧好嘞6是吧，
能吃辣吗？
可以可以好嘞好好，
谢谢哎呦呦呦呦，
长尝牛肉粉我想吃一个，
这个咋整？
嗯，
是，
这是基因里面附带的，
一看到有熊豆套老。
饭我们来一个牛肉粉，
好打包在吃，
估计就可以在这吃了吧，
没事，
你愿意打包也可以打包，
免费行，
那您给我打包吧，
诶带着多少钱呀，
这个5块钱15块钱啊好，
没有忌口啊呃，
没有忌口，
诶好嘞，
那我微辣要辣，
呃微辣吧，
微辣小微辣行吗？
微辣好吃好吃，
老板我们就是那个湖南人，
湖南贵州那块的老板也是湖南澧县的哦，
看到就走了道，
行，
谢谢啊，
我已经给您付了啊诶好嘞，
再见啊，
诶再见，
多少钱一个，
10块10块钱一个啊好嘞，
切成三份行吗？
可以是猪肉还是牛肉啊猪肉哦好嘞哇，
您切的可真均匀啊，
都尝一下，
对，
谢谢老板好，
这边的处好多人排队，
我们可能吃不上了，
别排队了。
好，
你先帮我拿着这个吧，
姐是不是准备掏出你的小礼物了？
对，
先拿出去哈喽哈喽hello喽hello，
我在海口碰到龙飞老师好漂亮，
谢谢，
我有点紧张，
龙飞老师本人比视频上的漂亮好几百岁，
我送你一个小礼物吧，
这是一个小扇子，
是我平时自己喜欢用的一个小扇子啊，
谢谢谢谢你，
谢谢你这个我会一直支持你的，
希望你发更多的视频，
然后帮助我们更多的广大网友女孩子，
希望你们作业好，
谢谢你那那我就不打扰你们了，
好的，
那你们玩的开心，
拜拜拜拜拜拜姐为什么刚刚你那么紧张，
知道就有点紧张，
有点血口啊不过那个小姑娘好漂亮哦对，
我们的粉丝都好漂亮哦，
看这是什么果呀水果好热情。
果是因为吃了会热是吧，
这个是什么的，
燕燕窝，
燕窝窝哦，
这个多，
这个也来三个，
大哥，
你那个屁股上有点烂啦，
这边上那个是这样不是烂的，
你该硬邦邦烂的是软的啦，
怎么的啦，
美女，
79加二十四一百一十三，
79+24，
等会儿啊，
49+24是一百百零一是一百零三一百零三对吧，
老板，
那我还是算了一下起好喝吗？
那个如果是冰的就更好喝了，
好，
谢谢，
我们回去拿我们的那个吧，
嗯，
拿我们的小龙虾还在吧，
完了有点不记得咱们买的是哪家了，
在这里吧，
热情火。
鸡得尝一尝，
老板说这个没有坏啊，
还给我特意捏了一下他们要不要豆包一下，
怎么吃，
感觉它长得像百香果，
哦哦哦哦，
有点意思吧，
哦，
不，
跟百香果一样，
没有坏吧，
很很甜呢，
很甜很香诶，
老板没有欺骗我，
哎，
而我这回给大家看一下哦，
甜甜的，
香香的，
有点像那个八月锅，
你们吃过吗？
嗯，
好吃的蛋皮肉我吞了应该没事吧，
好像是要嚼的，
姐，
我不早晚吃不豆嘴里嚼一嚼，
好像枣是可以嚼碎的，
而且籽儿不苦，
哎，
它好像就是嚼着吃的茧，
跟百香果一样。
嗯，
好吃吗？
好吃嚼，
嗯，
越嚼越爽，
但有点贵哦，
多少钱一个来着，
花香三十五一斤啊。
哦，
合下来好像要十几块钱一个，
嗯，
来海南吃北京的饼，
实在忍不住，
嗯，
迪香好的好的，
快别拍了，
快点快点快点，
贼香，
一秒入魂。
嗯，
好臭，
真的好香，
买呀，
这个北京这个饼太好吃了，
嗯，
下次还来，
好吃吧，
一会我们回去再买两个饼，
对，
明天做早餐都可以再就着这个饼吃你的粉，
两个都没有踩雷哦，
对吧，
水果没有踩雷，
饼也没有踩雷，
然后尝尝我们这个粉，
会不会来到海南了，
吃湖南粉也是没肥了。
嗯，
好吃，
很正宗，
哎，
很有我们湖南的那个味道，
好吃好吃，
真好吃，
是不是因为我们饿了，
有可能对啊，
我们是吧，
上飞机的时候，
上飞机的时候没怎么吃，
有可能是因为我们饿急眼了，
是公筷啊，
实名认证，
好吃。
龙哥，
燕窝果来会不会踩雷啊了吃这不是火龙果啊啊，
这个眼甜，
它有点像那个火龙果味的，
又有点像菠萝的吧，
不信你我一个试试，
真的这么好吃，
真好丰富的味道啊，
还有点西美的味道啊，
看我们这3个3套没吃过，
要回去的时候我们真开再买点再能带上飞机吗？
结果是不行哎，
海南怎么能不吃我们邻水的酸粉呢？
嗯的好，
这是东菜，
然后我用我自己的筷子就觉得一直在咽口水吗？
龙哥，
你是我心你尽好吃吗？
嗯，
好吃，
这小风一吹，
太舒服了，
干的。
又想来海南定居了。